what's cracking squad fam it's your boy
Peter Pat here it's time for an update
video it's been a while I'm going to try
and keep it brief but you know I would
love to make this [ __ ] ten minutes if I
could faria I just wanted to say to you
guys on that what's going on first of
all I just wanted to say thank you I
realized that something really great the
other day and I think is that I finally
enjoy my audience again sorry you're not
invited okay I still don't enjoy you go
away that's not to say that I never
enjoyed my audience I think back in the
day when I was starting off there was so
much just positivity and everyone was on
the same page on the channel and then
since he grew bigger than it probably
ever should have we got such a mix of
different people that wanted different
content and it just sort of became a
thing where no matter what I uploaded
there's always going to be people
nagging a lot of nagging and complaining
constantly and it's you shut that out
and obviously it's not fair because a
lot of people are still really cool and
still supporting what you do but for a
long time I just felt like you look at
your audience as a whole and you're just
like jesus [ __ ] christ what do you
want from me but I feel now when I've
taken a less serious approach to YouTube
and taking it more casual it's sort of
brought back and doing these weekly
weekly design interaction videos it sort
of brought back at an audience that I
can remember that seemed really cool and
really on the same page and I'm really
happy about that I'm just really happy
that I have an audience that I actually
really like I used to have just all kids
watching me back in the day and that's
fine but it also sort of makes me
question what the [ __ ] you doing I'll
still I still get comments though thanks
but anyway you guys are okay
it's what I'm trying to say but yeah
I've been like I said I've been taking
more
easier approach to YouTube and I also
think that's made my content less forced
it's just what it is you know if I feel
like I'm going to just play a game I'm
just going to play a game and you guys
have seemed really okay with that like
that's really cool and I'm happy about
that
I'm very just happy about that again and
I just been doing what I want to do
which sort of led me to just enjoy video
games again it's been it's been a while
I actually enjoy playing video games and
and sharing that with you guys so I
think that that's something I want to
keep doing so to sort of fill the more
time that I have now in between making
videos I thought I want it I want to
start streaming so I'm going to start
streaming Monday to Friday at least I'll
be I'll probably be live between 12:00 P
12:00 p.m. UK - for at least 4 or 5 p.m.
I British time not sure what time that
is for you probably doesn't work out for
you for that that's the time I'm going
to be live and I'm pretty excited about
that I think life change is one of my
favorite things I realized this is a
very boring update video but I just
wanted to let you guys know what's going
on and I really just again I just want
to say thank you I'm very very happy
that I have an audience that I enjoy and
also thank you for all the support on
the merch that we did it was a huge
success
I'm so happy that you guys bought the
March I'm legit head merch in the past
we're like three people bought one I'm
not joking haha and then you have to
explain to the people that helped you
make and be like well I guess people
didn't like it and it's not like you
have to buy merch to support me but it
it shows that it means a lot it just
means a lot and I want just thank you
thank you well there's no way I can make
this ten minutes so I'm just going to
end it here I'll see in the livestreams
I'll see you brothers and sisters in
videos and again just keep sucking dick